100 mil 306 sobredosis fatales en un
solo año es la cifra anual de muertes
por drogas más alta jamás registrada en
eeuu esto implica un fallecimiento cada
cinco minutos y un aumento de casi el 30
por ciento respecto al mismo período del
año anterior
la visualización de datos muestra un
aumento continuo de las muertes por
sobredosis hasta los 12 meses que
terminan en abril de 2021 y ahí hemos
alcanzado una especie de hito sombrío
las cifras superan las 100 mil muertes
para ese periodo de 12 meses lo cual es
bastante dramático tras conocer esos
datos el presidente estadounidense joe
biden anunció que prevé mejorar la
prevención así como el acceso a la
naloxona un antídoto capaz de
contrarrestar una sobredosis mientras
continuamos progresando para vencer la
pandemia de kobe 19 no podemos ignorar
esta epidemia de muertes que ha afectado
a familias y comunidades alrededor de
todo el país los expertos creen que las
sobredosis aumentaron debido al costo
físico lógico de la pandemia pero
también a la disponibilidad de más opio
y de sintéticos como el fentanilo y en
efecto nuevos datos muestran que muchas
de las muertes están relacionadas con
este o que hoy de altamente letal
travels a través tenía 21 años cuando
murió por envenenamiento con fentanilo
era un chico inteligente era un chico
guapo era divertido a la gente le
gustaba estar con él las sobredosis
aumentaron en todos menos 4 de los 50
estados del país llegando a superar a
las muertes producidas por armas y
accidentes automovilísticos